[Musique]
bonjour nathalie vol je vous fait
jusqu'à moins et nous allons parler de
livres pour la jeunesse
aujourd'hui avec deux auteurs deux
auteurs en effet elsa auriol et réjane
niogret bonjour elsa auriol bonjour et
jeanniot gré bonjour aux lf alors elsa
je vais vous présenter rapidement elsa
vous êtes auteur vous êtes peintre vous
êtes aussi illustratrice avait écrit
près de 30 albums des classiques des
comptes des textes que vous écrivez
vous-même ou que vous peignez quand vous
illustrer les textes des auteurs avec
lesquels vous êtes en duo
alors on peut citer la fille en bleu le
magicien il affine en bus le barbe bleue
dracula et moi et tant d'autres sans
compter vos collaborations avec la
presse vos expositions de tableaux
réjane réjane bonjour vous êtes conteuse
vos spectacles sont et à partir de
contes du monde et du patrimoine parfois
seul parfois que des comédiens avec des
musiciens parmi vos créations on peut
citer l'amour on peut citer les mille et
une nuits le merveilleux voyage de nils
holgersson et avec christian poslaniec
qui est écrivain
le grand spécialiste de la littérature
d'enfance et bien vous avez conçu une
collection dont on va parler dans un
instant qui s'appelle contes et poèmes
du monde entier batterie je crois que tu
as une question à poser à mi-voix ça
m'intéresse toujours de savoir pourquoi
on décrit pour la pour la jeunesse je
crois que c'est dit michel tournier qui
disait que c'est au fond de l'art le
plus difficile parce que il faut
simplifier son écriture son dessin
parfois mais mais mais mais mais qu'il
soit quand même un dessin où que ce soit
un dessin une écriture tout à fait tout
à fait correct est tout à fait originale
alors d'où est venu ce goût pour
l'écriture ou de la peinture ou des
l'illustration pour les enfants qui vont
commencer elle a peut-être alors je suis
plus dans d'illustration dans l'écrit
donc je suis peut-être pas la meilleure
bien placé pour parler de l'écriture
mais pour avoir un peu écrit à quelques
albums il faut avoir une écriture assez
fluide
je pense que les gens n'ont pas beaucoup
mieux que moi il faut avoir une écriture
assez fluide et puis surtout
compréhensibles par un jeune les très
jeunes lecteurs
voilà l'illustration par exemple est ce
que est ce que vous vous y feriez de la
même façon un livre pour adulte que vous
illustrez haut niveau pour enfants moi
au départ c'est la peinture qui
m'amenait d'illustration donc au départ
adressé plutôt l adulte et puis petit à
petit je me suis penché sur le domaine
des albums qui a un univers passionnant
et très riche c'est très stimulant pour
un peintre de pouvoir avoir un terrain
de jeu aussi créatif que le domaine du
livre pour enfants
alors effectivement quand on passe de la
peinture une peinture pour adultes à des
illustrations pour enfants il faut
adapter mais moi par rapport à ma
technique ce qui m'intéressait c'était
de garder la même technique donc que ce
soit pour la peinture ou pour les
illustrations
j'ai la même technique voilà de peinture
mais après bien sûr on s'adaptait
l'histoire alors elle ignorait dans
l'écriture voit la télé quel est
l'effort qu'on doit faire pour écrire
pour un public dizaine alors pour ma
part y vit en fait un élément clé pour
l'éducation
donc j'ai toujours été attiré par l'idée
que l'éducation peut vous pour la
société le tout un mode des bars dans
l'éducation et donc dans mon idée il
faut là je n'ai vraiment revenir à la
parole première qui transmet les valeurs
humaines et j'aime écrire j'ai toujours
aimé enfant j'aimais les mouches des
maîtres la faveur du verbe et
transmettre cette beauté de la vie à
travers les mots est rentré de les
valeurs avec beaucoup de délicatesse qui
ne font pas de les détendre les rassurer
votre piscine et bien sam sont
fondamentales
voilà pour les enfants ou les adultes
aussi bien sûr mais les enfants pour
devenir est vraiment dans les niveaux
totalise beaucoup elsa on va parler de
l'un de vos dernier album qui s'intitule
riquet paru aux éditions l'étagère du
bas qui est une jeune maison montante
dynamique alors vous êtes fidèlement
inspirée d'un célèbre conte de charles
perrault qui nous invite à une traversée
initiatique avec un destin croisé de
deux personnages que tout oppose on a le
prince riquet qui est très laid il est
caractérisé par sa houppe
mais d'une rare intelligence et l aile
la princesse du royaume voisin
eh bien elle et à elle est très belle
mais elle est affreusement stupide alors
elsa parlez nous un peu de ce pouvoir
universel de l'amour et puis on a envie
aussi de savoir pourquoi vous avez voulu
faire revivre ce conte traditionnel est
ce qu'il ya un écho à la période
contemporaine où on fait beaucoup de
deux places à au paraître et à la mise
en scène de soi sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux
alors donc il ya plusieurs questions en
une je vais essayer de vache barriques
et déjà pourquoi riquet parce que
c'était un décompte qui m'a le plus
marqué quand j'étais enfant et je ne
sais pas pourquoi au fil du temps ce
compte a disparu des recueils de contes
de perrault
on avait gardé la belle au bois dormant
cendrillon
le petit chaperon rouge le petit poucet
enfin peut-être j'en oublie encore
beaucoup mais riquet à la houppe avait
disparu alors je comprenais pas moi
c'était un conte qui en forme avait
énormément marqué justement parce que ce
prince est complètement atypique
ce n'est pas la la la la caricature je
vais dire du bellâtre qu'on trouve à
chaque fois qu'il vient qui réveille la
présence de la princesse d'un baiser là
il a fallu qu'il aille au delà de son
apparence pour séduire une princesse qui
elle était tout le contraire de lui
voilà est ce que j'ai pour en revenir à
l'amour universel
je crois que c'était l'amour existait
avant nous ça existera après et c'est ce
qui nous anime tous dans cette vie que
nous traversons c'est la quête quand
même de l'amour c'est quand même la
chose la plus importante
l'âme soeur voilà est là dans ce conte
riquet chacun est le miroir de l'autre
et donc ces deux âmes soeurs qui se rend
compte et qui étaient faites pour se
rencontrer et il ya quelque chose dans
la douleur du miroir où chacun se
renvoie ce que l'autre espère avoir mais
chacun je souhaite c'est clair ce que je
dis chacun va révéler est ce que l'autre
crois ne pas voir ses lames et
l'ajustement voilà ils ont écrit c'était
un mythe qui avait été déjà repris par
amélie peloton il ya deux ou trois ans
dans 1 c'est dans un de ses romans
mais quand même le le mec les est
intelligent et la fille belle et les
bêtes quand même aujourd'hui c'est pas
un truc à part une vision un peu
réductrice un peu réductrice et des 10ès
qui est réductrice voit peu le bateau
quoi ma plage et on peut pas de compte
avec vous alors cessé il faut remettre
ça dans le contexte de l'époque c'est
quand même une écriture du xviie siècle
moi je les
et je les verrai réinterpréter déjà pour
le fus dit fier le fluidifier parce que
la version 2 0 était pas même un peu un
peu dur pour des enfants
je trouvais et puis oui c'est vrai qu'il
ya quelque chose d'un peu cliché je suis
d'accord avec vous mais ce cliché est là
pour servir de une rencontre où
effectivement enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est ce qu'on peut voir dans plein de
rencontres en général dans deux
personnes qui se rencontrent
on a chacun un peu une part one un
complexe voilà hélas ce qui était
intéressant c'est que ces deux là vont
avoir chacun un complexe qui vont
surmonter
c'est un peu ce qu'on voit et que vilain
petit canard ou dans la belle et la bête
il ya sept ce complexe qui va être réglé
par le miracle de l'amour et je crois
que quiconque a été amoureux dans sa vie
un jour ça va venir peut dire que la
rencontre de de l'être aimé révèle chez
soi des choses qu'on ne soupçonnait pas
et donc cette fille
oui dont le septet un peu cliché
effectivement elle est belle et bête
c'est un énorme cliché complètement
d'accord méric et hélas pour lui dire le
contraire oui tu es belle mais non tu
n'es pas bête et et moi je te regarde
avec bienveillance et c'est la
bienveillance qui va révéler chez elle
son intelligence parce que tout est une
question de regard qu'on porte sur
l'autre mais dans tous les domaines dans
l'amitié dans au travail quand quelqu'un
vous fait confiance et qui vous regarde
avec bienveillance vous donner le
meilleur de vous même
c'est ce que ferry quai 17 filles et
avec cette belle et donc elle révèle le
meilleur d'elle-même
cette intelligence qu'elles concernent
va voir mais qu'elle a et lui cette
beauté qui ne pensait ne pas avoir mais
elle le regarde avec tellement d'amour
qu'il qu'il se sent beau il est beau
voilà alors parce qu'il faut quand même
à part une de ce dernier livre petit
tambour rouge et maman de l'eau que vous
avez écrit avec christian passe la
niaque c'est une anthologie de contes et
poèmes et ce qui est merveilleux c'est
que grâce à la littérature et bien on
voyage on voyage de cuba tobago guyane
nicaragua et cetera réjane pouvez vous
nous parler de maman de l'eau ou alors
cette créature mi ds mi sorcière alors
neuf ans j'ai voulu bousculer timbre est
vraiment dans une échappée avec deux
autres ouvrages précédents et un qui va
arriver à qu'à prier nous faisons
vraiment le tour du monde en compte et
en vo m et pour chacun seul ouvrage
inventant une victoire pour présenter
les victoires en quelques tas à chaque
fois ce sont un écrin ce sont des cracks
tendrement liés aux textes que nous
écoutons avec elle très bientôt
elle apporte tambours nous avons imaginé
un petit bateau qui accorde un jour à
cuba un jour à trinité et tobago un
autre jour ou bbva qui va enchanter un
enfant par une musique est vraiment une
musique du pays un rythme du pays avait
le sommes depuis barça fait le tambour
bèlè de martinique elles tomberont pas
de guyane est extrêmement variée et
l'enfant charme et va quitter ton
quotidien sauter dans le bateau être
transporté au rendez vous avec la mort
du lot et l'aveyron de lourdes est
vraiment un personnage qui existe dans
le match dans les deux cas ait un qui
est vraiment la déesse de la mer mais il
est un peu portée et nous nous en avons
failli conteuse qui raconte des contes
des caraïbes a fortement fondu pays de
l'enfance et qui convoque les amis pour
dire des poèmes et pas d'autres
personnes dota fois contemporain de de
tout effort des caraïbes est vraiment
des textes de poèmes et je sais dire que
le livre qui porte sur l'asie paraîtra
en début de toujours dans la collection
contes et poèmes paraîtra en début
d'année prochaine
et ça je voulais qu'on dise en moi aussi
que de que d'émotions
un album kits aux éditions kaléidoscope
que j'ai publié avec christiane hohmann
villemin et alors ça c'est le drame
enfin où le drame où l'émotion d'un
petit enfant qui va jouer son spectacle
de fin d'année un c'est ça oui mais tout
à fait c'est donc c'est pas ma première
collaboration avec christine de
maneville main on a eu la voit là
l'opportunité de faire plusieurs livres
ensemble au sein de cette belle maison
qui est calé de scop avec qui j'ai fait
la grande majorité de mes albums
voilà et ce petit garçon bas va passer
par toutes les émotions possibles parce
qu'il va projeter les émotions qui va
pouvoir exprimer dans son spectacle de
fin d'année
voilà qui fait le tour de toutes les
émotions et c'est sous la plume de
christine mcvie demain c'est un régal
voilà d'accord elsa jeu si vous avez
peint des demandes dans cet album c'est
ça vous avez fait des acrobaties en
peinture ah oui oui un pari avec un bras
gauche comme à droite en ce sens oui je
suis gauchère et à chaque fois que
l'enfant projette une émotion j'ai
trouvé intéressant de le traduire d'une
façon enfantine et pour trouver ce très
enfantin ben j'ai pris la main avec
laquelle je n'ai pas l'habitude de
dessiner c'est à dire la main droite qui
mafieux qui permettent de retrouver une
naïveté perdu malheureusement vous
retrouvera pas au ca montreuil cette
année qui est magnifique salon consacré
à la littérature pour la jeunesse mais
on peut retrouver évidemment vos livres
alors on les rappelle peut-être nathalie
gravel rapidement ricky elsa auriol
parution l'étagère du bas titan boue
rouge est maman de l'eau réjane niogret
christian passe la nuit avec parution le
temps des cerises et puis que d'émotions
elsa auriol parution est bien calé nos
scop et 15
les quinze dragons de jab paraîtra de
elle annulerait paraîtra en janvier
prochain au début de l'année prochaine
d'autres cas merci merci beaucoup à tout
et 2 merci pour tout est à livre merci
merci examen ciré jaune merci à vous
merci
[Musique]